aux états unis après ans malgré la
défaite à la présidentielle donald trump
ne savent où manifestement pas vaincu et
continue de faire parler de lui même
s'il est bannie de twitter de facebook
et d'instagram depuis l'assaut de ses
partisans contre le capitole de 6
janvier dernier
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter sur place sur ma
bonne et en direct de washington au soir
thomas plus de quatre mois donc après
son départ de la maison blanche donald
trump continue de faire parler de lui
régulièrement les médias américains
évoquent même la possibilité de son
retour où il appelait la possibilité de
son retour est un sujet qui est très
régulièrement discutée dans les
émissions de débat ici aux etats-unis
mais cette fois c'est un tweet d'une
journaliste du new york times qui a
provoqué beaucoup de réactions selon à
maggie habermann l'ex-président
américain aurait confié à des proches
qu'il s'attendait à être réinvesti à la
maison blanche d'ici le mois d'août
un message qui a provoqué la polémique
sur twitter certains reprochant à l'adie
de journalistes de relayer de fausses
informations
il faut dire que ce tweet intervient au
lendemain d'une autre polémique
provoquée par michael flynn l'ancien
conseiller à la sécurité nationale de
donald trump lors d'un meeting
un spectateur lui a demandé pourquoi ce
qui fait passer en birmanie ne pourrait
pas se produire aux états unis faisant
référence au coup d état militaire qui
est venu en birmanie
sur quoi michael flynn a répondu je cite
il n'y a pas de raison ça devrait avoir
lieu alors malgré le rétropédalage de
l'intéressé cette phrase a relancé les
polémiques autour des agissements de
certains des soutiens de donald trump
pour contester le résultat de la
dernière élection présidentielle
alors de son côté thomas à l'ancien
président a décidé de s'investir au sein
du parti républicain
oui s'il fut un temps question qu'il
crée son propre parti donald trump
semble aujourd'hui déterminé à garder
son influence dans le parti républicain
pour preuve il sera à ce week-end en
caroline du nord pour la convention
républicaine de cet état une étape parmi
d'autres puisque donald trump prévoit
d'autres meetings en juin et en juillet
avec pour but est d'apporter son soutien
à ses fidèles et à se maintenir un
cercle influent au sein du parti
républicain
alors selon certains analystes
politiques l'idée pour donald trump
serait de participer à la réussite des
républicains justement lors des
élections de mi-mandat en 2022 afin
d'arriver en bonne posture pour la
présidentielle de 2000 24 non non on en
n'est évidemment pas encore là mais
force est de constater que malgré les
procédures lancées contre lui et malgré
son bannissement des réseaux sociaux
donald trump reste encore très populaire
auprès de sa base
selon un sondage ipsos pour reuters paru
en mai seulement 28% des républicains
pensent que donald trump ne devrait pas
se présenter en 2024
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington